- I do this podcast called 'Unqualified',
and it's a relationship podcast
and we give people relationship advice,
attempt to, 'cause I'm really bad at it,
'cause I don't know what I'm doing.
And I wish I could swear,
- That's funny
because I would emphasize
that point even more,
- but maybe the dogs will.
- Is there anyone though
that you feel like on your,
'cause people have asked
me now that I have a show,
Is there anybody, anyone
I'm dying to have on?
Is anyone you're dying
to have on your podcast?
- Little Kim.
- Lil Kim?
I love you right now!
(laughing)
That's awesome.
Most people would be, like,
- Hey, you guys can feel it.
- That's awesome.
Why Lil Kim?
I love this.
- Well, okay the first
red carpet I walked,
It was for the MTV Movie Awards,
and Little Kim was right behind me
and she was just wearing,
what do they call those things?
- [Audience Member] Pasties.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Pasties!
- Yeah, pasties.
Somebody knew that right away.
- She's got some on right now.
It's on.
- Pasties.
- That's how we roll.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yes.
- I'm not gonna lie if I
worked that hard for that body.
I might show it off like that.
Oh, you can't eat the flowers,
look at Dante!
Of course I picked the psycho, I love it!
(audience laughter)
- Get it Dante!
Dante you got another flag
on the play coming bro.
You're gonna you're gonna
vomit, you shouldn't eat that.
So you'd love to have her on your show?
- Yes, yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] She'd be interesting.
She'd be a cool guest, I agree.
- If we get her,
because it'll be with your help.
- I will.
We are sending out a pigeon right now.
Lil' Kim, you need to do 'Unqualified'.
I did, it's amazing.
I'll do it with you.
We'll all get on, there you go.
- Yeah, pasties or no.
We will accept you any which way.
- Pasties, anything you
want to wear, it's fine.
Everyone is welcome.
(audience shocked)
- That was Dante too!
- [Man] It was Dante.
Dante, you need to calm down man!